[Music]
two-month-old muhammad is lucky to be
alive
[Music]
born eight weeks premature in a village
all but wiped out by drought
deca his 17 year old mother traveled 400
miles to get him to hospital and didn't
think he'd make it
she was very very upset and worried
about her condition first time he she
came she was worried like
he will die
i know
she was very very very like
worried and she is pain about the child
and she doesn't sleep
he still looks desperately ill but
doctors say he should survive
many like him haven't
the ward is full they're putting
patience now on the floor
one-year-old muhammad has been given a
nasal tube to feed him urgently needed
fluids
ward dr abdul rahman says he's afraid of
what could be on the way
the rains are not come early the city
will come once day by day and the number
of bridges that will increase it even
hour by hour day by day and we cannot
handle it or we cannot save them
right across the horn of africa they are
bracing themselves for the double impact
of war and famine the worst drought in
40 years is combining with the effects
of russia's invasion of ukraine the ball
there may be thousands of miles away
from these markets but it's pushing up
the prices of grain and fuel to
unprecedented levels making the impact
of the drought
even worse
[Music]
the drought now threatens the worst
famine for years camps are already
filling
with people who've lost any means of
supporting their families
the parents are desperate
[Music]
like sophia a few months ago well off by
her standards she's now destitute she's
had to move to the camp after the
drought killed all her livestock
my grandfather was a goat herd my father
was a goat herd i grew up in that life
and ended up with 500 goats and four
camels and they've all been wiped out
i've got nothing now
[Music]
the rains have failed for a fourth year
with no grass left for the goats they
pull leaves from trees to eat
[Music]
but getting food to the people who need
it will be a huge challenge
across the region millions are facing
acute hunger in the worst drought in
over a generation compounded by the war
in ukraine and without massive
international help agencies say hundreds
of thousands will die of starvation
dominic waghorn sky news mandera
somaliland